how to build a universe in a computer
and not just any computer a super
computer what's the jaws phrase we're
going to need a bigger boat are we going
to need a bigger computer we always need
a bigger computer i've built
universities in various computers we
have a supercomputer-ish here that it
has about 000 processors or something
which you can do some universes in but
if you want to go for the really big
ones i used a big one in switzerland
with 128 000 processors so you log into
it across the internet and
put your thing in so the first thing i
did was type in you know how much free
space have i got and it came up with 1.6
petabytes so i had to look up exactly
what a petabyte was because i thought i
knew but that device is a thousand
terabytes there's a huge amount of space
available
but it's frightening how quickly you can
get through that space
firstly you have to have something that
is suitable for a supercomputer so it
has lots and lots of processes
so you have to have a job that can be
divided up into little bits
and it also has to scale reasonably well
so if you double the number of
processors does it halve the amount of
time or does it just bring it down a
little bit
and so if you go to 100
000 cpus does it make it a hundred
thousand times quicker or does it just
make it 20 times quicker that's sort of
thing you need to know before you start
and then once you've done that then you
have to set up the uh the whole
environment so it's a batch environment
you submit your job say this is what i
want to run i want to run it on this
many
processors
i want this amount of memory available i
want to
i'm going to write this many files
and that goes off and disappears into
the sort of ether and then at some point
the batch system will come around and
say right i've got enough spare room to
run your job and off it will go
it's usually sort of late sunday night
or something like that so you can
arrange for an email to come
and so an email will pop up and said
your job has started and it's very often
followed by another one saying your job
is finished
or aborted
because you've made some error that
you you're not quite right so you
normally start with a small subset of
cpus and make sure that everything is
going to work and just run it for half
an hour or something like that and then
you go
bigger and bigger until you're confident
that it will run across the whole time
when you're working out whether you can
parallelize this it's like a person
digging a hole with a spade if you give
them a hundred spades they can still
only dig at the same speed absolutely
yeah but then if you give a hundred
people one spade they still can only
take the same speed
you need that magic 100 people with 100
space right yeah and you also even if
you've got 100 people 100 spades they
can't necessarily all get to the hole
there's always going to be some
restriction that's going to slow you
down so
you know it's it's it's trade-offs for
those things how do you get around those
restrictions what's the what's the way
of organizing it
uh you just have to sort of divide it up
so in the case of this we're building a
universal so we build up little sort of
quadrants or
or tiny bits of universe and
a small group of processors will work on
that and another group will work on a
bit of it over here but eventually they
do need to communicate because stuff
grows up here and the gravity affects
the stuff over here so they all have to
communicate but you can go for a little
while with sort of ignoring the outside
or just working with the previous
version of the outside world and then
you have to
chat amongst yourselves and say well
this is the new state of it and then you
can run for a bit further so it sort of
goes in those lock steps
every so often and also because your
programs are not necessarily bug free
you save the state of the universe so
you you run for you know half a billion
years or something of
effectively
universe time and then you save
absolutely everything you can
so that um well you know everything
everything collapses you've at least got
that
but you can also
tell the program to start from that what
we call a call it a snapshot of the data
so you can start from there and then run
from there so if it all does fall over
but you've
you've got a few billion years into it
you can at least start from that point
and
carry on i think the clickbait title for
this has got to be how many times you
save the universe
that would be a great click leak yes
yeah yeah so having saved the universe
how much data are we talking here for a
universe safe
well it depends uh exactly how big or
how fine ingrained you're going to make
it but you know typical simulation is
probably a billion particles we use to
simulate a universe each one of those
has an x y and z coordinate it has a
velocity so v x v y v z
sometimes we keep mass or sometimes we
just have all particles with the same
mass
sometimes we have other bits and pieces
of information that we can work out at
the time that are worth saving but it's
fairly large um
you know it's in the sort of terabyte
range
for each of these snapshots
and we might save
five or six hundred of these over run so
that
once we've completed it and we found
something interesting uh you know in
today's universe we can actually track
that back through the snapshot and say
well how did that feature arise you know
if we wander back we can see its history
so you want all that data saved
so yeah it's pretty big so as i said you
know 1.6 petabytes
but uh
you're going through
you know two or three terabytes each
snapshot you save i'm just now thinking
that those petabytes are not very close
to us here what's the process of getting
the data from the supercomputer to you
well it's it's over the internet and
it's typically frantic
so another problem you have with the
supercomputer is you only have it for a
certain amount of time so you have
allocated research time and you know i
was finished on i think you know march
the 31st
so sort of the beginning of march you
start to think about getting that data
off there
and
even with the fastest uh
internet connections it takes a long
while to transfer you know many
terabytes of information
and you've also got to work out where
you're going to store it because you
can't
we haven't got terabytes of
spare space just hanging around
so i do remember walking around asda
looking at these stacks of dvd roms that
you could buy and thinking i wonder how
many of those i need to put in my
shopping cart to actually store all this
it turned out to be far too many so we
didn't go with that
so eventually we did find somewhere more
locally that we could store it
so you want to store it and then you can
process it and start to analyze it and
look for patterns in it but it's
something you need to think of not at
the last minute because it takes
typically weeks to transfer this amount
of data and that analysis the analysis
doesn't happen on the supercomputer or
is it just that you might use it and
load it in somewhere
you can do it on the supercomputer
sometimes we have done it there but
you you as well as having a time budget
you have a cpu budget so you have so
many million hours or something of cpu
time
so you could use it for running the
simulation and you could use it for
analyzing it
or you might want to spend all your time
running the simulation to
its sort of nth degree and then do the
analysis somewhere else
somewhere else has to be quite big to
read in these large amounts of data and
process it but it's it's more tractable
so we could run that on our nottingham
supercomputer rather than
but then you've got to transfer the data
you know a chunk of time over to that
computer and let it run and process it
this is the old argument about a truck
full of hard disks
exactly yeah i was thinking
could i just fly over to switzerland and
pick up the data in a couple of large
suitcases might that be quicker but
anyway it wasn't asking to print it out
for you
punch cards that's the way it's the
future
if we just scroll forward in time we can
see that as things start to happen we
get to this point where
everything starts to reroute and rather
than going directly to facebook you can
start to see it all w this is some
actual cipher text that we'll be
breaking later does it honestly start
with zoos as in conrad's views
yeah the reality of random